today on the matt walsh show we are
witnessing an infinite expansion of
gender and sexuality identities though
all the new identities seem to be
repetitions of each other why is this
happening exactly where is it coming
from i have a theory that i'll share
with you also five headlines democrats
begin their latest investigation quote
unquote into the events of january 6th
california introduces vaccine mandates
and john oliver pushes for reparations
and also new polls show that most
americans
don't think that men should compete
against women in women's sports and yet
that's exactly what's happening why
we'll talk about all of that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
i'd like to start today with a video not
unlike so many others that we've played
on this show you know generally what to
expect at this point a person of unclear
sex rambling incoherently and parading
out a whole encyclopedia of new gender
and sexuality labels that all seem to
mean the same thing and nothing at the
same time
and if that's what you're expecting well
you're exactly right
is the kind of thing i would normally
say for the end of the show but but
there is a larger point to be made here
i think so first i must subject you to
the video uh and here it is
non-asexual aromantic and allosexual
aromatic are not always interchangeable
non-asexual aromantic includes
identities such as my own i'm not
asexual but i'm not allowed sexual
either my experiences are going to be
very different from an allosexual
aromantic person's
i think it's just important if you're an
ally who's talking about aromantic
issues if you're talking about
allosexual aromantic issues
make sure to say allosexual aromantic
there is nothing wrong with that term
just saying non-asexual aromantic also
includes other aromantic people who
might not experience sexual attraction
but still don't identify as asexual
just something to keep in mind
indeed
indeed i will keep that in mind and
thank you for that reminder i'd actually
been thinking about these very issues
recently in fact i was sitting around
with some guys drinking beer and
debating the finer distinctions between
allosexual aromantic asexual and
non-asexual aromantic we'd actually draw
a four-ringed venn diagram just to keep
it straight but now
we know and uh and that is very good so
thank you for that now for anyone
confused allosexual
may sound like the name of a dinosaur
from the late jurassic period but it's
not um you're thinking of allosaurus
an allosexual person is not an extinct
reptile nor is he necessarily attracted
to them though he could be
no an allosexual according to webmd
means anyone who experiences sexual
attraction
yes any sort of attraction at all makes
you an allosexual so even if you didn't
want to be an allosexual it didn't feel
the need for an additional label to add
on to your
sexual orientation you have it anyway
there it is just take it and be grateful
you brat
as for the other labels just listed an
asexual person is somebody who allegedly
experiences no attraction to anyone
however an aromantic person is someone
again i'm using webmd here a site that
sometimes makes me think i'm dying
and at other times like now makes me
wish i was
an aromantic person is someone who
experiences no romantic attraction to
others but may still be sexually
attracted
so someone who who isn't very romantic
but is still sexual
may be considered aromantic
every woman listening right now is
thinking oh you mean like literally all
men
yes perhaps but we should note that
aromantic people can not only still be
sexually attracted but also can
experience quote intense loving feelings
so a sexual person who experiences
intense loving feelings towards another
person isn't that the same thing as
being romantic perhaps again but who
cares we're on a roll here let's keep
going and please do not confuse
aromantic people with demi-romantic
people those are those are those who
have romantic attraction only after
forming an emotional bond with another
person
and every man listening is now thinking
oh you mean like literally all women
there's also uh lithoromantic or ocoyro
romantic these are people who experience
romantic attraction
but don't want it to be returned
so they want to be romantically
attracted to you but they don't want you
to feel anything to them
otherwise known as creepers
and don't forget gray romantics those
are people who experience romantic
attraction sometimes
but not other times
otherwise known as everyone
and then there are
choiromantic people who
uh can't tell the difference between
romantic and platonic attraction
once again that simply describes every
male member of the human species
now um
i know what you're thinking
what about panromantics
well you're either thinking that or
something more along the lines of please
stop talking about this
assuming it was the former i can tell
you that healthline just published an
article about pan-romanticism
which says quote
pan-romantic and asexual are not
synonymous they're two different
identifiers with two different
definitions someone on the asexuality
spectrum could use both identifiers in
order to best name their lived
experience with romantic pan-romantic
and sexual asexual attraction but
identifying as one doesn't imply
identifying as the other while your
sexual orientation names who you want to
have sex with if anyone your romantic
orientation names who you want to spend
time with well romantically if anyone
romantic orientation names who you feel
a pull toward who you desire to cuddle
or make dinner with and who you want to
spend all your time with explains gray
sexual panromantic l rose founder of
asexuality spectrum resource secret lady
spider and co-host of the invisible
spectrum podcast i don't even know what
any of the words i'm using mean
panromantic i feel like i'm having a
stroke as i read this
pan-romantic is one of the many romantic
orientations other romantic orientations
include homoromantic heteroromantic and
biromantic someone who's
pan-romantic can experience romantic
attraction to someone regardless of
their gender she explains okay
so that's that's the that's the breaking
news here we've got sexual orientation
but also romantic orientation
that's the latest thing hot off the
presses okay just dropped romantic
orientation
you may notice that the explanations
offered by these people always seem to
do the opposite of what an explanation
typically is meant to achieve
they explain things in order to make
those things more confusing and obscure
rather than less
that's nothing new we know that there
are dozens and dozens of sexual
orientations which combine with dozens
and dozens of genders to create
thousands of different variations
though the variations seem to be
incredibly redundant describing the same
basic thing in different ways with
differences that are more meaningless
than subtle
we've talked many times about where this
proliferation of identity labels comes
from
and why so many people become so
obsessed with endlessly labeling
themselves
but now i'd like to travel deeper
i don't know if i'd want to travel
deeper but i'm going to
into the mindset of these people
all the way into the dark cavernous maze
of their convoluted egos
and see if we can't come up with a more
complete answer
what really is going on here
because it is something significant and
consequential
why are so many people especially young
people and not a small number of them
wasting their lives by trying to
categorize themselves
i thought i was boring because i'll sit
around on a saturday on a saturday
organizing my fishing tackle
that's a fun saturday to me
but these people or even my sock drawer
as much of a stereotype as that is i
will i will do that
and i kind of enjoy it but these people
spend hours every day
sifting through their own psyches and
dividing themselves into smaller parts
and putting each part into its own
drawer with its own label
what kind of a bizarre hobby is this and
again why
well i think a few factors are
converging to create this perfect storm
of total nonsense
many people today of all ages but
especially those who grew up in the
internet era
have spent their entire lives including
all their formative years
staring blankly into screens
now this not only exposes them to all of
these new contrived identities but more
importantly
often prevents them from developing any
functional skills or hobbies outside of
cyberspace
these are people who don't know how to
do anything
and don't desire to do anything unless
it can be done by moving their thumbs
across a screen
or video game controller
there are obviously exceptions to this
general rule but the fact is that
teenagers today spend almost all of
their leisure time on screens um
and we all know that intellectually but
i think we often don't sit and really
reflect on the implications of it a
report from a couple of years ago said
that the average teen is using a screen
seven hours a day not including school
work
and i think that estimate is probably
low
but
assuming it's not seven hours and then
school work
that's just every hour of the day that's
the entire there is there's no time for
anything else
there's no time to do anything else or
find any physical or creative outlets
which means there's also no time to
develop anything like an authentic and
unique personality
a person begins compulsively
self-labeling not in order to understand
their own personality but as a
replacement for it
that's why the newer sexual categories
all seem to be centered around androgyny
they're not discovering their identity
but right rejecting identity it's an
anti-identity
opting for something dull and indistinct
where they're all allegedly being their
authentic selves but end up looking
exactly like one another
and together they look like nothing a
dreary blend of two sexes where all that
is beautiful about both has been lost
and only the most superficial aspects
remain
it's tempting to say that we're turning
people into sexless robots
that's not quite the case
see a robot has no sense of itself no
self-awareness
um that's the case everywhere but in you
know sci-fi in reality robot has no
self-awareness
but the other hallmark of the modern
western person is that he is fanatically
self-aware
he is consumed by his awareness of
himself he is aware of almost nothing
but himself in fact he has the exact
opposite problem of the robot
while the robot cannot think of cannot
cannot think of itself
he can't think of anything else
he is obsessed with figuring out what he
feels
and how he feels about what he feels and
how his feelings about what he feels
make him feel and on and on and on an
endless spiral a black hole
now i'm skipping some steps here
admittedly the internet the lack of
identity the narcissism the
self-obsession
these only lay the groundwork
we still need the cultural influences to
come in and introduce these concepts
giving the empty people a framework that
appeals to them in their emptiness
but they're only spreading fertilizer on
ground that is somehow both sterile and
yet fertile
so so what happens in the end when a
person has no personality
and yet can do nothing but stare back
into the void of himself
trying to discover an authenticity that
he's long since destroyed
well this is what happens
modern culture is what happens gender
theory and pride flags with a thousand
contrasting colors are what happens
a person with no life
and who has had no experiences telling
us to respect his lived experiences
that's what happens
along with suicide and drug abuse and
society beset by
meaninglessness and despair
ultimately
civilizational collapse is what happens
but the good news
is that we get some funny tick tock
videos out of it so
try to look on the bright side
now let's get to our five headlines
now quick word from bambi you know i'm
not a business owner myself but one
thing i hear from business owners all
the time is that this is something
that's only getting worse over time not
better is that hr issues are what really
can kill you because you've got wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations a lot of
red tape that you have to wade through
and i'm guessing that you didn't get
into whatever whatever your business is
as an entrepreneur you didn't get into
that uh in order to deal with red tape
and and all this kind of nonsense and
that's why you need bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
it was created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy and maintain
your compliance all for just 99 a month
which is a lot better than the 70 000 a
year on average that hr manager salaries
will run you with uh bambi you can
change hr from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength and your dedicated
hr manager is available by phone email
real-time chat they're there for you
it's and by the way you're paying this
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time there's no reason not to
try this so go to bambi.com walsh right
now to schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com walsh spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e dot com slash walsh
uh anyway
uh you know i wanted to mention because
i i have this undeserved reputation as a
hater of animals maybe because i always
talk about how i hate animals but
uh in spite of that i did allow my kids
to get a new pet so that's big news in
our house uh and actually they kidnapped
the pet more like i mean rescued it it's
a it's a pet it's a turtle a baby turtle
that they found
and the turtle is it's it's like it's
damaged it's disabled it has uh it's
like half of its foot is missing and
it's got it's a cracked shell
um
really kind of a hideous little beast
but they wanted to keep it
and we said yes but then get this
um i go to a
the pet store
that shall remain nameless it's a big
giant
chain
pet store type of place
um
and i go in
and i tell the guy that we we have this
turtle and i'm looking i'm trying to be
responsible
like i'm like what's the right kind of
aquarium
um do you have one that costs less than
six thousand dollars because all of
these things for a glass box the prices
here are ridiculous uh what do i need a
heat lamp or something like give me give
me that give me the basics here i'm
already spending more time on this
than i wanted to spend
but i'm trying to be responsible and the
kids like it and so i'm trying you know
that's what i'm trying to do
and the guy refuses to help me
because he said that we're not supposed
to take turtles out of the wilderness he
won't help me he refuses to he takes
like this this ethical stand
and i said okay
but the thing is a [ __ ]
and we
my kids are saving it it would be dead
out there okay it'd be bird food
and he said this is what he actually
said is what he actually told me this is
what he recommended he said call the
tennessee game warden and have them come
take the baby turtle oh really that's
what you wanted me to do let me get on
the phone and call the game warden and
say we got this baby turtle with one
with a leg missing come and come and
take it are they really going to waste
their time on that
anyway the prices were too expensive so
i just i ended up leaving and we ordered
it online anyway um
and i had to control myself because i
wanted so bad
to get into an argument with this guy
but i also you know my kids are there
it's like do i want to start yelling at
the the guy at the pet store in the
middle of the aisle making a scene i i
decided
pardon me thinks i should have but but i
decided not to
but um
you know i'm just thinking afterwards
what you you sell animals here where do
you get them
like where you come off getting all high
and mighty where these animals got these
animals aren't out in the wilderness
you sell them
how dare you
and now i'm uh and now i'm thinking
maybe i shouldn't even be talking about
this publicly because apparently it's
illegal what we did now there's gonna be
a swat team breaking down my door trying
to free the disabled turtle all right um
let's move on
the january 6th commission is underway
right now democrats are
having their investigation this is what
their 10th or 11th investigation they've
had into these events
and um
i'm not going to play any clips of it
right now not gonna talk much about it
because i really don't care and the
whole thing is nothing but political
theater
um
and that's it
that that's all that i think really
needs to be said about it
if it were anything but that you know if
you want to prove to me prove to
everyone that it's that it's not
political theater
then after you're done your little
january 6 commission
um then next i want you to have a summer
of 2020 commission
where we talk about the riots that
plagued our country for months and
months on end and which cost billions of
dollars of damage and killed dozens of
people
and left hundreds of people without jobs
and without their homes and their and
their livelihoods taken away from them
that's what i want to know about
i don't know how i want to know how this
was allowed to happen
i already know the answer but that's the
investigation how did this happen how
did that happen how was that allowed to
happen
where were the governors of these states
where were the mayors
well we know where they were
in many cases they were out in the
street
explicitly encouraging it
calling for more of it
we know there are high ranking elected
democrats
explicitly calling for more unrest
going way further than donald trump ever
did
because donald trump never called for a
riot he never said
he never called for unrest
he never used any euphemism for riot
the democrats did with the blm riots
how is it that uh that blm militants
were able to invade a police station
in the middle of a major american city
and burn it to the ground
how did that happen
so that's the investigation i want of
course that investigation is never going
to happen
and that's how we know that this is
nothing but uh but political theater
that's why i refuse to care
any conservatives so-called
conservatives or republicans who go
along with this
and pretend
that this is some sort of good faith
effort to get to the bottom of it get to
the truth
and if you're playing that game you are
either stupid beyond all repair or
something way worse than that
and i'm thinking probably the latter
all right next from fox news california
state employees and health care workers
will need to show proof they've gotten a
coven 19 vaccine or get tested weekly
under a new mandate according to state
officials who announced this on monday
the new rule which will take effect next
month comes as the state looks to slow a
rising number of coronavirus infections
and hospitalizations primarily affecting
those who are not vaccinated
though the number of new cases is still
well below the peak
at least 238 000 state employees and 2
million healthcare workers across public
and private sector will be subjected to
the new mandate
so we're seeing the
the
vaccine mandates officially begin now
starting with state workers is it going
to stay only with state workers and
government workers i highly doubt it
governor newsom was on cnn talking about
this and he made an analogy that i
thought was
interesting and also ridiculous let's
listen
is it time governor to bring back a
universal mask mandate uh regardless the
vaccination status there in california
look we don't even have to have that
debate if we can just get everybody
vaccinated that's not vaccinated that's
refusing to get vaccinated this living
vaccine free and impacting the rest of
us it's like drunk drivers you don't
have the right to go out and drink and
drive and put everybody else at risk
including your own life at risk
california is one of the highest
vaccination rates in america but yet
we're still seeing an increase because
so many people 25 in california
are refusing to get vaccinated so we're
really trying to focus on ending this
pandemic once and for all those
non-pharmaceutical interventions like
face coverings and face masking were
necessary in the absence of vaccines but
with these vaccines we can extinguish
this virus once and for all and get it
behind us and not worry about getting
our kids safely back into in-person
instruction or keeping our businesses
open uh we're encouraged by the uh local
determinations as it relates to mass
covering mask wearing uh but at the end
of the day the real focus here get
vaccinated so we can end this pandemic
yes um the the
the vaccines work
they're safe and effective
also get the vaccine or you might infect
me
why would you question the effectiveness
of the vaccine that doesn't make any
sense that's absurd
i have it and it's working now please
get it or i might die
what's the problem why are you confused
don't you understand
i have a vaccine it's really safe it's
working it's great
you don't have the vaccine and if you
don't get it then you're going to kill
me
what what's the problem here why are you
staring at me like you're confused
oh oh because my the messaging here is
completely confused and convoluted and
makes no sense and contradicts itself
from one sentence to the next okay well
that's why
drunk drivers
okay see there's no vaccine here's the
difference
he says that uh not getting a va not
getting vaccine is is like being a drunk
driver
um
there's no vaccine against drunk driving
is there
you could wear a seat belt
but if someone crashes into you
you know head first collision at 60
miles an hour whether you got the
seatbelt or not you're you're you're
probably done for
um are you saying that the vaccine is
only as effective as a seat belt in a 60
mile per hour collision
which is to say
doesn't really do much at all
or often doesn't do anything
because if you're say if you want us
to believe that the vaccine is effective
then that message messaging doesn't make
any sense at all
either the vaccine works or it doesn't
that that's it
either it's effective or it isn't
ch choose one or the other
if your message if you're if you're a
manner
of uh
your strategy for getting people to take
the vaccine
is to talk about the vaccine as if it
doesn't work at all
then that is not going to be an
effective strategy
just a
just a thought
all right this is from usa today it says
paypal is collaborating with the
anti-defamation league on research aimed
at cutting off funding for extremist or
hate groups
in a statement monday adl said the
research will explore how extremist or
hate movements use financial platforms
to fund their activities
both that organization and paypal say
the results of their research will be
shared within the financial industry
also policymakers and law enforcement
the chief risk officer and executive
vice president of risk and platforms at
paypal said in a statement by
identifying partners across sectors with
common goals and complementary resources
we can make an even greater impact than
any of us would ever do on our own as
part of the initiative paypal and adl
adl will also form a coalition with
civil rights organizations to protect
marginalized communities from extremism
adlc ceo jonathan greenblatt said we
have a unique opportunity to further
understand how hate spreads and develop
key insights that will inform the
efforts of the financial industry law
enforcement and our communities in
mitigating extremist threats
so that's the story here's a
relevant part of the adl stat statement
on this new initiative
it says the initiative with paypal will
be led through adl's center on extremism
a leading authority on extremism
terrorism and hate
paypal and adl
will focus on further uncovering and
disrupting the financial pipelines that
support extremist and hate movements
in addition to extremist and
anti-government organizations the
initiative will focus on actors and
networks spreading and profiting from
all forms of hate and bigotry against
any community
this is a financial institution teaming
up with uh
anti-defamation league which is really
just a left-wing advocacy group
in order to target hate and extremism
nothing to worry about there right
of course there's a lot to worry about
and this was guaranteed now
we should have been worried about this
you know back when concepts like hate
speech
took hold
um
or even
using a word like extremism or an
extremist
as if it's an objectively bad label
you know that's to be extreme in your
views
whether or not that's a bad thing it
really depends on what the view is
if you're if you're correct
um if you are in
truth
then there's there's no way to be too
extreme there's no way to be too extreme
about the truth
extremism becomes a problem extremism is
a is a problem of degree
if you're wrong
and you're
you know
and you're extremely wrong then that's
going to be even worse than than being
sort of moderately wrong
so all of these were extreme
radical oh we wouldn't want to have
radicals this bad thing to be a radical
well it really depends doesn't it
depends on what your cause is what your
movement is
fundamentalist is another word related
to that
it's a bad thing to be a fundamentalist
talking about religious people
yeah it's bad to be a fundamentalist if
the fundamentals of your religion
are flawed
but if they're not then yeah you ought
to be a fundamentalist
just means abiding by the fundamentals
of your religion
if the fundamentals of your religion are
violent
then yes it's a problem to be a
fundamentalist there
so it really depends and that's also the
case with hate
is it a bad thing to hate
again it depends it depends on what you
hate
and why
everybody hates things it's part of
being a human being
hate is the other
is is the the other side of the coin to
love they're on the same coin
in fact in order to love something you
must also hate
example
um
i love my children
more than life itself
and because i love them
there are many things that i therefore
hate
primarily anything that threatens to
hurt them and cause them harm
anything that that wishes to corrupt
them
you know
i hate that
it's a big reason why i hate um
left-wing gender theory critical race
theory because of of the harm that it
does to kids who are indoctrinated into
it
but we have as a society and including a
lot of conservatives we've gone along
with this idea
that all hate is automatically bad
hey you don't want to get engage in hate
speech is like a different category from
regular speech see there's regular
speech which is okay and that's when
you're giving your opinions about things
but uh hate speech is a totally
different thing and that's bad because
it means that you're using speech to
convey that you hate something
well it's only bad it's only bad
sometimes
depends on what you're hating right
it's extremism is a radical
fundamentalist we allowed all of these
words to become
uh objectively bad
in our culture
and now and now this
and now there's a by the most powerful
forces in our culture on a campaign
to erase hate and extremism
and on the surface level who could
possibly object they just want to get
rid of hate hate's a bad thing right
hate speech is different than regular
speech we've already apparently we've
all agreed with this and established it
but because it all
depends now it's going to be a matter of
the question is well well
okay
what what type of hate are you going
after here
are you going to be targeting people
what about those who would hate someone
like me
for being a white conservative male
what about that kind of hate speech
i know we're going to leave that alone
because that's the good hate
um all right
moving on this is from the daily wire
john oliver host of uh hbo's fake news
show last week the knight believes the
u.s government should pay monetary
restitution to black americans to
commentate for the country's past racism
he argued sunday night the only really
strange thing about it is that we
haven't done it yet
um citing a 2014 atlantic art article
the case for operations the british
comedian based his arguments not on
slavery but on housing discrimination
oliver said the history of race and land
ownership in america has many horrifying
chapters pretty much from chapter one
when america was discovered from under
other people's feet
despite the fact that the fair housing
act first acted in 1968 makes it illegal
to consider race or skin color in the
sale of homes oliver contended that
minorities still face discrimination
when it comes to federal mortgage loans
and home appraisals the comedian also
blasted colorblind proposals like joe
biden's fifteen thousand dollar
first-time homebuyer tax credit and made
an argument specifically for race-based
policies
uh anyone off about 30 minutes here
advocating for reparations of course but
the first thing i'm going to say anytime
someone advocates for reparations
um and if you are a white person
yourself john oliver is worth i think
worth 30 million dollars maybe more than
that
with your net worth and all the wealth
that you have
how many black families could you lift
out of poverty on your own
if all of the wealthy white liberals in
our country who who say they want things
like reparations
talk to talk to any pretty much any
hollywood celebrity any white hollywood
celebrity ask them what they think about
reparations and they're going to tell
you oh yeah absolutely we need that
i i'm enlightened of course i'm in favor
of that
okay well
what about what about selling one of
your seven mansions
and going into one of these
underprivileged cities and you know
giving out the profits
well no because you want
you don't want to be the one to pay you
want other people to pay the reparations
of course
in fact when i brought this point up
some people uh
observed that john oliver is british
although i think he's now an american
citizen
technically well he's british and so uh
i was actually told this
on twitter that it's well he's british
and he he just came to this country
recently and none of this is his fault
well a couple things here first of all
um yeah that's part of the point about
reparations isn't it
that even if i were to agree that you
could inherit
guilt from your ancestors
meaning that now you have to pay up for
the sins they committed which i don't
agree but even if i did
a great number of the white people who
live here now myself included
weren't our our bloodline our
our ancestors weren't in this country
when this stuff was happening
and in fact for many of us when our
ancestors did come here
they also faced discrimination and
prejudice so how do you work that out
that's the case for me as a person of
irish descent
and speaking of uh john oliver
being a brit
okay maybe he should be paying his own
reparations then
for the sins of his ancestors pay them
to me pay them to the irish i'll be the
first i'll cut me the first check i'll
be first in line
and that's that's always going to be the
first um
problem with any call to reparations
is that so often the people calling for
it
are in a position where they could start
doling it out themselves of their own
volition and they choose not to which
tells you something
but also you know
when we talk about
past discrimination
uh bad things that happened in the past
and how that is responsible and that has
led to
the situation we look
that we face today
my first question is going to be what's
going on in the family
so before we can talk about reparations
at all how about this
let's get the fatherless rate
in the black community let's get it down
it's a 70 right now or more depending on
where where you know depending on what
community specifically we're looking at
around 70 percent
let's get it down to
30 which is still really high
but what would happen if we got that
fatherless rate down to 30 percent
where only 30
of black children are growing up in
fatherless homes
because i'm gonna bet that if we were to
do that
a lot of these problems that we blame on
historical racism would start to go away
or they would at least improve
dramatically
how's that for an idea when we start
there
let's get down to 30
and while we're at it we can work on the
fatherless rate in every other community
because it's it's it's too high
everywhere for everybody
and and then we can then we could check
back we could check back in on this
issue
i would even make that deal you know
what
if that doesn't move the needle at all
then all right fine we'll do reparations
that's how confident i am that it will
all right um this is from the daily wire
also it says americans are deeply
divided on the issue of transgender
athletes and most americans even most
democrats believe that athletes should
not compete against others of the gender
with which they identify according to an
axios poll out on monday the poll seems
to indicate a consensus among among
americans that transgender athletes most
often biological males should not
compete according to the gender with
which they identify if that gender is
different from the biological sex they
were assigned at birth
there does not appear to be a consensus
however on who athletes
who identify as transgender should
compete against
axios notes that the poll shows a deep
division but overall just 20 of
respondents said that transgender
athletes should be able to select which
team they compete on
um it says quote while 39 percent of
people say transgender athletes should
compete against others of the gender
they were assigned at birth
20 said they should compete against
others of the gender with which they
identify
and
uh it says while americans disagree
while americans disagree seems to be
over
well americans disagreement i guess i'm
supposed to say it seems to be over
where transgender athletes fit in around
40 of respondents said transgender
athletes should compete against others
of their biological gender okay this is
all very confusing
because it sounds like you have a
majority of americans on both sides of
the political aisle who say no men
shouldn't to simplify the language here
what they're saying is no males should
not compete against females
but not all of the people saying that
are willing to also say that the males
should only compete against males so who
should they compete against these are
they're really the only two options
either male or female
should males compete against females
most people say no of course not oh so
you mean that they should only compete
against males and then half the people
say well no i wouldn't go that far
what i think we can get from this
because the the results are
totally confused and don't really make a
lot of sense on the surface
um what i think we can glean from this
is that most people know
that men shouldn't compete against women
most people know that intuitively they
recognize that because it's obvious
but
they're they're terrified of their own
common sense
they don't want to go they don't want to
take their own common sense logic all
the way to its
not only its logical
conclusion but the only conclusion which
is that if males aren't competing
against females they're only competing
against males
but people are so afraid they they know
that this is crazy
right and left i think most people know
that this is crazy doesn't make any
sense
we're gonna have a a male
um
weightlifter competing against
females in the olympics that's coming up
in a few days so you can tune in and
watch that
laurel hubbard i believe is is the man's
name laura hubbard who wouldn't would
not
would not be able to compete at all
against the men
mediocre at best against the men
wouldn't make it onto the field wouldn't
come close to even
sniffing a qualification as a male
but put him against females and he
dominates because that's how
profound the differences are between the
sexes physically
and i think most people look at that and
they intuitively recognize this doesn't
make any sense it's completely
ridiculous
but they are terrified to recognize that
and so they want to take it all the way
to its logical conclusion they certainly
don't want to talk about it very much
and although most people recognize that
it's wrong these policies are put in
place across the country
not only in the olympics and in colleges
but all the way down to
high school and lower levels than that
and most of the people who recognize
that it's wrong don't say anything about
it
you know a lot of conservatives look at
these kinds of poll results and they're
encouraged by them
but me maybe not surprisingly as a as a
i i kind of take it the other way
i would almost given the fact that these
policies are being put in place across
the country and most people simply go
along with it and don't protest it i
would almost rather that the poll
results show that 90 of americans think
it's okay to have males competing
against females
because 90 90 of americans are going
along with it
i would rather believe that they're
going along with it because they
honestly believe this is the right thing
in some ways i would rather live in a
country full of
really confused people
than a country full of cowards
which i think is what we have
okay i'm reading the youtube comments
now this is from gibberish says matt
today your shirt color is blue and white
with a checkered pattern i'm sure you
were wondering was my shirt color
yesterday of course
and now i'm getting these comments a lot
people telling me what my what what
clothes i'm wearing and what color the
clothes are and i appreciate that
as a color vision deficient american i i
do appreciate that
um
chloe says matt you better not forget
about me when you're famous well i'm
already famous and i've already
forgotten about you
i'm sorry those
uh ryan says your arguments for
conservatorship are just poorly thought
out
well sir your argument has persuaded me
thank you for that i i abandoned my
previous position
i love these comments you get people you
make an argument and you lay it out i
mean i laid out my argument with the
conservatorship yesterday for like 15
minutes
and then someone says uh actually you're
wrong about that
period
oh okay
well never mind then
um
old schooled says matt please make this
the last time you waste our time on
brittany
fair enough but give me credit because
people were talking about the britney
spears thing for months
and and and i didn't say anything about
it
i think i showed incredible restraint
um but then i couldn't take it anymore
and i had to run my mouth so i can only
it was really it was once i found out
that the republicans
are
some republicans are trying to push
legislation the save brittany act that
for me was the last straw and i couldn't
i had to i had to say something
frederick says you are truly a pathetic
and bitter little man you have never
achieved an infinitesimal amount of the
beauty and joy john lennon has brought
into the world
well maybe but john lennon released the
plague known as imagine onto mankind
and uh he should never be forgiven for
that
okay
i i have never committed an atrocity as
bad as that
though he's not as bad as paul mccartney
who is responsible for
wonderful christmas time
which forever will be the worst song
ever written
um
genie says matt i don't agree that
britney should be under conservatorship
if she can't if she can work in las
vegas doing shows several nights a week
she deserves her own money and time
yeah i hear this a lot that to me makes
no sense the fact that someone can get
up on stage and sing and perform a
choreographed routine
um even if they're really good at the
choreography and the dancing and
are
moderately okay at the singing part of
it
that doesn't prove anything about their
psychological state
you could certainly be
totally psychotic and do that
so i don't think that really proves
anything in and of itself
um
and kurt says
i like this show please don't get me
wrong i'd like it even better if you did
a show slamming the right's shortcomings
i think i do that a lot don't i
the right loves regulating things the
war on drugs for one is immoral i should
be able to ingest any damn thing i want
well you can ingest any damn thing you
want
kurt
i mean you could drink a bottle of
gasoline if you wanted to i wouldn't
recommend it please don't but you could
there's no law to prevent it
or if there is a law there's no law that
could prevent you from doing that we
should say
the question though at least for me
here's the question
because you said ingest any damn thing
you want okay let's take gasoline
um
there there are probably laws saying
please don't drink gasoline but no one
can actually stop you from doing it
the question is whether it should be
legal
for the gas station to put the gasoline
into bottles and sell it to you for the
purpose of drinking
even if they tell you it's going to kill
you
put it on the label should they be able
to do that
my answer is no
i don't think it should be legal
to sell poison to people in any form
something that is purely poison
and really can't do anything but damage
you and eventually kill you
i don't think that should be legal
and finally william says us sweet babies
must address matt as daddy walsh
uh no that's that's too weird let's back
it down a little bit
sweet baby gang obviously sweet baby
gang for life i'm into that but uh don't
call me daddy walsh
obviously you should be calling me sweet
daddy walsh
and i'm gonna so badly regret having
just said that i know i will
exciting news to share with you all
today ben shapiro's newest book the
authoritarian moment hits bookshelves
today and if you're thinking didn't ben
shapiro just put out a book recently he
did but he he he's somehow able to write
like two books a year while it takes me
about
five years to write one i i don't
understand how he does it physically but
he does and all the books are really
good also um and he's doing his live
stream book signing tonight at 7 30 p.m
eastern 6 30 p.m central delhiware.com
ben shapiro youtube and ben shapiro
facebook you can order your limited
edition signed book now for just thirty
dollars at dailywire.com ben
i told you yesterday that it was your
last chance to order that book i lied to
you it's not my fault they made me like
i just read was on the paper turns out
you could still order the book so do it
now it's a pretty good deal if you ask
me especially because you can submit a
question right now when you go to
purchase your signed copy again that's
dailywire.com
ben
and also is there anything more
terrifying than a bunch of communist
world leaders all deciding to be
extremely communist and tyrannical at
the same time i don't think so you have
cuban cubans being thrown in jail for
protesting their authoritarian
government the streets the french facing
police violence as they protest
the enforcement of vaccine passports
newsom cracking the whip and sending la
into lockdown mode yet again and that's
happening across the country and perhaps
the most frightening of all our own
president is colluding with big tech to
increase censorship of dissenting
viewpoints governments all over the
world including ours are trying to
squeeze their citizens for every last
drop of freedom that they have and
unfortunately they're succeeding that's
why it's time for your favorite voices
of reason oh okay we're finally getting
to the part where i talk about the
backstage i was wondering when that
would happen um when we're gonna have a
backstage is what i'm trying to tell you
ben shapiro uh myself jeremy boring
michael knowles and andrew clavin are
gonna be heaven backstage tomorrow it'll
be another cigar packed session of
backstage it's been a terrible this has
just been an absolute disaster you know
it's you guys know about it the other
thing is with the backstage
event we kind of end up talking about
everything so you never know what we're
going to talk about but i guess this
will be the primary topic of
conversation it streams this wednesday
at seven o'clock p.m eastern 6 p.m
central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel daily wire
don't miss it and don't make me read
this copy again now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
our daily cancellation comes in some
ways full circle from the opening
monologue our focus is on a man named
rob rousseau who described himself in
his bio as a flamboyant writer whatever
that is supposed to mean exactly on
sunday he tweeted this he said do you
ever just sit around and suddenly
remember that you've been living through
an unprecedented traumatic crisis event
for the past year and a half and will
probably be dealing with the profound
psychological consequences for years to
come lol
now as always on the internet the
comments are what tell the story i think
many people like to say that the
internet isn't real life and it isn't
that's correct you can't live a real
life on the internet as previously
discussed but it is however largely
populated by real people
not counting all the bots
um so the way people act the things they
say however they comport themselves on
the internet is then a reflection of the
sorts of people that exist in reality
that's a chilling thought i realize but
it's an inescapable inescapable
conclusion all the same on that note
here are some of the comments under
rob's post and there are hundreds more
where these came from i'll read a
um
few
tend to cloak my own psychological uh
on this site but small what this doesn't
make any sense
i tend to cloak my own psychological
trauma on this slight but small reveal
primary trauma was five years ago when
trump got gop nod and then won the
general it felt personal intentional
like discovering a portion of my
friend's family acquaintances secretly
wished me ill
another says this
i was dealing with anxiety and
depression already but trump's election
damaged my trust in the world in large
ways it's so frustrating knowing this
was all coming for five years and seeing
so many oblivious to it drove me mad now
i'm just angry all the time
wait a second you knew that the
coronavirus pandemic was coming for five
years
and you didn't tell anybody
look we might need to circle back around
to that one another comment says
definitely never had anxiety before now
i'm anxious about everything example the
thermostat broke in my refrigerator
rather than having it fixed i brought i
bought a large mini fridge because i
didn't want a possible disease infested
repairman in my house
disease infested repairman
that's not elitist at all is it
another says no i sit around and realize
we're watching an entire world in
free-fall and wonder if i should gently
talk my children out of having children
because at this point in 30 years the
planet may be unlivable with global
warming and raging covet variants caused
by the selfish and the cruel
another says trying try being black on
top of that the last 30 years my every
waking moment is psychological trauma i
have to laugh at through memes to
function the next day
if a cop doesn't shoot me in the face
first
then a pandemic on top
okay
it may be comforting to imagine that
these are the ramblings of a small
assortment of paranoid schizophrenics
but what is comforting is not always
true and it certainly is not true in
this case the sad fact is that a large
portion of the population
feels this way
they have fashioned themselves survivors
of a near-death experience though the
experience isn't over in their minds it
never will be
and they believe that uh what they're
living through is as the original post
said unprecedented
the horror which we have suffered but
mostly which they have suffered has no
analog in human history
they think
and it's an easy mistake to make if your
knowledge of history extends no further
than i don't know a decade or so into
the past
in truth of course and this is really
important to understand to put things in
perspective
there is nothing at all unprecedented
about the pandemic itself
nothing
it'll take you about 15 seconds on
google to discover many examples of far
deadlier outbreaks the most obvious one
that comes to mind is the black plague
of course which killed half of the
population of europe
now by comparison in the u.s
covet has killed about two point
i rather should say 0.2 of the
population
so that's 50 percent
versus a tiny fraction of 1
almost none of those deaths have been
children thank god or young people
the vast majority have been the elderly
or sick or morbidly obese now it's still
a sad and terrible thing no doubt
and you can call it a sad and terrible
thing without hearing any objection from
me
if you would if you just say well
kovit has been sad and terrible
but of course it has been i agree
but if you call it unprecedented
and speak of the lifelong trauma you'll
now suffer because of it i have to
remind you that your real issue is your
own ignorance and self-absorption
now with that said
there was one unprecedented element
element of this pandemic our response to
it has been unprecedented
trying to shut down the whole world and
the global economy for a year
that is unprecedented
people who are not at any high risk
wearing medical masks every day all day
everywhere they go for a year or more
that is unprecedented
but an unprecedented reaction to an
event does not make the event itself
unprecedented
you know i might scream and run away
from a spider in the house but the fact
that i'm reacting to the spider in a way
that no other self-respecting man ever
would
doesn't mean that the spider is actually
the biggest spider anyone has ever seen
by the way though just a hypothetical
example i would never react to a spider
that way
as far as you know
are people actually traumatized by all
of this though
i mean certainly if you nearly died from
it or if a loved one did die from it or
almost die from it
um
then then i don't doubt that you're
suffering psychological wounds wounds
that from from that experience
i mean if you lose a loved one doesn't
matter how you lose lose them
we can call that a traumatic event
but many of the people talking about
their trauma didn't actually have a
traumatic experience with the virus
i could only assume that rob didn't
that's why he said lol at the end of it
i mean i assume if a close family member
died he wouldn't be saying this was a
traumatic event lol
i wish i could say that you know these
people merely think that they're
traumatized but i think the truth is
worse and more disturbing
it's more accurate to say i think
that um
lots of people wish they were
traumatized
because we've come to see trauma as a
fashionable and desirable thing
that's that's where we get this very
modern phenomenon
of people bragging about their trauma
and discovering trauma everywhere they
look
not just in global pandemics
but someone looks at them the wrong way
or says a word they don't like it's
traumatic
you talk to a lot of people these days
and they suffer traumatic every in fact
one of those comments said every every
waking moment is a traumatic event
because that's what they that's what
they wish that's what they want
they've come to sort of fetishize uh
trauma
and and
back
when everybody lived a hard life
almost everyone did
this this is most of human history by
the way again for perspective
most of human history
for the majority of time that the humans
have occupied this planet
almost everyone on the planet with the
exception of the absolute most
wealthy and powerful
everyone else lived lives of deprivation
and suffering
and they died
often horrible deaths
at much younger ages
and they had to have a lot of kids
because they knew that some of their
kids would die it was just an expected
thing
you think they went around every day
talking about their trauma
bragging about it
no they didn't have time for that
because they were busy living and
surviving
which was a job which was work
in our culture people are so comfortable
and have gotten so accustomed to the
ease of life and the luxury of it
that they have the they have now the
luxury
of making a fetish out of trauma
which brings us back to the beginning
people without personality or identity
who seem to think that trauma
makes them interesting
and it's sort of a replacement for
personality
and all of that is why
i forget even who we're canceling now oh
yeah rob rousseau the flamboyant writer
is today now canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show morning wire on today's
show the justice department decides not
to investigate nursing home deaths in
2020 house democrats assemble a january
6th committee and tensions rise as u.s
diplomats sit down with chinese
officials join us and get the facts
first on the news you need to know with
our show morning wire